würdest du er in einer wüste oder im
meer verloren sein um diese und viele
weitere fragen geht es im heutigen video
denn ich spiele heute endlich mal wieder
also ich bin ganz ehrlich ich würde hier
ganz klar die wüste nehmen und wenn
damit auch in der mehrheit einfach
durchgespielt mehr was macht ihr areal
talk mehr sinn weil er mehr hast du so
viele sachen die unter dir sind in der
wüste weise zumindest okay wenn ich gehe
dahin nicht hier und vielleicht hat man
die chance eine fata morgana mal zu
sehen und dann sieht man dass so ein
mcdonalds oder sonnek würdest du er
keine augenbrauen haben oder eine
augenbraue haben
dann gar keine
bruder ich dachte heute alles richtig
würdest du eher haifischzähne haben oder
gar keine zähne haben dann die bei fisch
zähne 380 ist natürlich da kannst du
alles einfach zerreißen würdest du er
nie wieder heißes essen essen können
oder niemals eine heiße dusche haben
können ich glaube nie wieder eine reise
dusche auch wieder mehr halt ich kurz
verliert eine falsche statistiken
reinigen und die zahlen rechtsradikaler
ich würdest du er ein berühmter rockstar
sein oder ein berühmter filmstar ich
glaube es ist beides nicht so ganz
entspannt weil wenn ich mich entscheiden
müsste dann glaube ich ein filmstar
ich sag euch ab jetzt wird alles richtig
sein müsste eher schlechte ratschläge
geben oder schlechte ratschläge erhalten
die sache ist dass ich mit ratschlägen
eni so träumen also wenn mir jemand dass
uns das empfiehlt das ist eigentlich
relativ egal
weil schlussendlich entscheidet ja was
ich mache oder nicht von daher würde ich
eher schlechte ratschläge erhalten
glaube ich mehrheit
würdest du er einen berg besteigen oder
fallschirmspringen bruders württemberg
in
das ist gelogen die beantworten das
nicht ehrlich denken falschen springen
ist cool aber nähe bruder
fallschirmspringen größter selbstmord
würdest du er auf einer party unsichtbar
sein oder das leben der partie sein
ewiger und sich
opel stress voll im mittelpunkt stehst
würdest du eher 50 chicken nuggets essen
oder sechs big macs
50 chicken nuggets
die sind zwar bodenlos und ich es ja
auch nicht mehr aber wenn ich mich
entscheiden müsste dann definitiv das
würdest du er mit den bloßen händen
gegen einen wolf kämpfen oder mit einem
schwert gegen einen großen bären mit dem
schwert
wolf ist ja viel agiler sogar nochmals
tim b also das war klar willst du eher
1000 dollar zahlen um nie wieder eine
werbung sehen zu müssen oder weiterhin
werbung an schon werbung anschauen
also ich bin ganz ehrlich werbung ist er
für jedermann gut und ich selber erfahre
auch viele dinge nur durch die werbung
und weist ein okay jetzt hab ich das
gesehen das ist cool das will ich jetzt
haben und so funktioniert es also ich
find werbung wenn sie gut ist echt nice
liebe auch die kinowerbung immer voll im
film ich komme immer pünktlich nur um
die werbung zu sehen würdest du eher ein
glücklicher versager sein oder
unglückliche erfolgreichen
glücklich kite lasst euch das wirklich
gesagt sein ist immer das wichtigste
würdest du eher eine limousine haben
oder ein cabrio nemo da keine limousine
also kam ich bin ich so ein riesen fan
von aber wenn ich mich entscheiden
müsste dann definitiv kabel weil mit
einem musik parkplatz mordopfer das ist
gar nicht würdest du die reichste person
der welt sein oder eine super kraft
deiner wahl haben
gib mir alles geld der welt dann brauche
ich doch keine superkraft mehr von wegen
was sucht ihr euch aus dass ich fliegen
kann jack auf den privatjet
dass sich unter wasser atmen kann
koffein u boot doch sich zum mond
fliegen kann kaufe ich mir rakete wenn
ich der reichste mensch der welt bin
kann nicht alles machen würdest du er
keine knie haben wollen oder keine
ellbogen war etwas
diese ich darf keine ellenbogen weil
knies sollten wir mehr hat die knie sind
unser wichtigstes gelingt weil darauf
stehst du ja
vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht sein
wichtigstes klein habe ich jetzt einfach
mal dazu beschlossen würdest du er im
alter von zehn jahren heiraten oder
überhaupt nicht heiraten dann überhaupt
nicht denken dass wir so knappe mehrheit
hätte ich nicht gedacht weil mit zehn
jahren dann kommst du dich damit zehn
jahre nur noch mit dieser das ist also
da hat ja die besten jahre noch vor die
nie ein auto besitzen oder nie ein
haustier besitzen
ich liebe autos aber ich liebe auch
hunde
ich war zufällig
das habe ich gedrückten auto egal wenn
dieses gab es dann bist du eher ein
fünfminütiges bad nehmen oder eine
zehnminütige dusche dicker
auf jeden fall die dusche
das macht doch gar keinen sinn ich hasse
baden und das mit der dusche dauert
sogar noch länger ist also klar ich hab
sogar ich hasse baden so toll dass die
männer kölner wohnung bat einfach
herausgerissen verkauft habe also nicht
damit immer wisst wie sehr ich baden
wirklich ab verabscheut würdest wird er
wahre liebe finden oder zehn millionen
dollar gewinn ist etwas viel liebe
würdest du eher eine dusche haben die
dich sieben tage lang sauber hält oder
ein bed haben dass die eine volle
nachtruhe in einer stunde ermöglicht
becker das bett
ist euch mal aufgefallen dass wenn man
acht stunden pro nacht schläft das
einfach ein drittel vom tag ist ein tag
hat 24 stunden das heißt wenn man jeden
tag acht schon schrift schläfst du ein
drittel deines lebens wenn man 80 jahre
alt wird wie heißt du stehst 26 jahre
ich hätte so gerne panel dass ich nie
wieder an katar gekommen oder ich hätte
gerne eine pille durch die unter wasser
atmen kann eh bruder gibt eine pille
dass ich keinen schlaf braucht das wäre
das krasseste der welt würdest du eher
zelten gehen oder nach las vegas
[Musik]
also da ist real tor gerade die frage
gestellt worden ob man lieber die ganze
nacht in der gefahr wäre von 12 auf
gegessen zu werden zecken zu bekommen
irgendwie aufwacht um vier uhr morgens
wenn dann die sonne aufgehen oder weil
irgendwelche wanderung näher gekommen
oder fix nach las vegas schädiger ortes
casino schrift und schön hotels geil was
essen würdest du er niemals altern oder
niemals sterben
glaube ich wird niemals alter nehmen ich
will gar nicht unsterblich sein ich
glaube irgendwann will man dann so 80
oder 90 werden könnte also kann man ja
aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das schaffe
ich glaube dass wenn du dann so gesehen
hast dass deine kinder erwachsen sind
dass deine kinder vielleicht auch schon
kinder haben und dass viele freunde von
mir vielleicht auch schon gestorben sind
dass man noch gar keinen bock blick aufs
leben hat und was man wirklich denkt
okay ich habe es geschafft mein ipad
zehn prozent ab da kann man auch guten
gewissens sterben
deswegen also in denen die mal also
altern ist mir auch egal aber ich will
halt einfach wirklich nicht unendlich
alt werden jeden auf der welt persönlich
kennen oder in der lage sein mit tieren
zu kommunizieren
ich glaube ich würde lieber jeden auf
der weltkarte nicht kennen wollen
die wirte nähe haben mit zum nacktmull
reden wollen als dass donald trump die
auf der straße in check gibt da läuft
seine angel vorbei die sagt luca was
geht
bei justin bieber auf barbecue
eingeladen werden hier dann wieder um
die welt jetten in australien mit dem
bürgermeister in den kaffee trinken
bruder was jungen nicht kängurus
nacktmulle und irgendwelche daten mit
denen ich reden könnte aber gut wenn ich
mit freunden erstellt wie ich das heute
gewinnt jetzt auch beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann lässt gern einen
daumen hoch unter dem video abonniert
einen kanal und klickt auf die glocke um
weitere videos nicht zu verpassen
hat glaub ich den vertracktesten
mikrofonarm von allen youtube in
deutschland aber auch ein neues video
auf den zweit kann dann heute
hochgeladen
hat ja nicht anschauen oder jemand kanal
abonnieren
würde ich nicht machen weil das salz
konnte